deux poids lourds un soir en rentrant
michel forget est a eu une bien mauvaise
surprise pour cet ancien policier qui a
passé 26 ans la sûreté du québec c'était
la deuxième fois en trois ans il se
faisait voler sa voiture en chantant du
train j'ai constaté que mon véhicule
avait dit ce père qui était stationnée
juste ici l'ondé lumière certains
appellent voir s'ils étaient remorqués
projet le bienvenu brand à l'évidence
c'était le deuxième but
malgré toutes les avancées
technologiques dans le monde de
l'automobile le vol de voiture demeure
un enjeu bien réel qui peut être lourd
de conséquences pour les victimes
l'acceptation sociale d'un vol de
véhicule c'est que ok c'est pas un crime
ça dérange pas les gens minces faudrait
que ça dérange pas les gens ça les
dérange
moi j'ai de la misère à maturité pour
terre j'ai toujours été un bon père
d'assurance j'ai jamais eu de
réclamations et tout à coup de vol bang
bang je peux l'assurer
techniquement c'est pas sans cosse en
conséquence on voit son ca vous
apprendre en s'amusant
l'entreprise tag est spécialisée dans le
repérage de véhicules volés
l'enquêteur recherche actuellement un
véhicule qui a été rapporté volé ils
seront pas la sauter depuis 2007 le
gouvernement fédéral avait obligé toutes
les manufacturiers automobiles d'avoir
un antidémarreur d'origine sur le
véhicule à toi cooper qui a fait que le
jeune joe wright sauveur il n'était plus
capable de voler un véhicule
il faut qu'on soit toujours en avant la
technologie sauf qu'après une décennie
de baisse de patrons tag constate que
depuis deux ans le nombre de vols de
voiture à montréal est de nouveau à la
hausse
ce nom-là expérience encore de 7 à 8%
ces deux réseaux spécialisés spécialisée
dans l'exportation clandestins de vic à
l'exportation le coût du véhicule et le
double pour le prix qu'on a ici au
québec
alors si on vole
un véhicule qui voguera mail au québec
mais quand on exporte dans les pays
choisis il va falloir 80 mille dollars
les douaniers savent très bien que
plusieurs voitures volées se retrouvent
dans des conteneurs au port de montréal
y en a énormément à l'heure actuelle la
part de montréal est une plaque
tournante voiture volée la drogue et un
paquet de choses s'éclairent tout le
monde le sait si c'est bien connu mais
il manque de volonté de vouloir
intervenir au port de montréal
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire qu'ils
manquent trente agents avoir un nom
d'argent suffisant on pourra faire un
meilleur travail c'est sûr les douaniers
doivent se concentrer essentiellement
sur la marchandises qui rentrent au pays
le syndicat soutient que tout ce qui
sort est beaucoup moins surveillés c'est
beaucoup moins qu'à 1% et fouillé d'un
connard beaucoup moins que important car
on constate qu'une voiture était volée
et elle se prépare à quitter le canada
donc est exportée nous on avertit les
autorités compétentes nous presser 1,10
grc pour les à montréal et souvent ce
qui se passe ni un ni l'autre semble
avoir d'intérêt pourquoi ce rôle mais
parce que souvent c'est pas très payant
pour les corps policiers
c'est à dire que les sentences cas que
ces gens sont pas encore les sentences
sont minimes
ni la grc ni la police de montréal n'ont
voulu nous accorder une entrevue par
courriel la grc explique qu'il y à
enquête si un lien avec le crime
organisé ou le financement terroriste a
été établi par les services de police de
première instance
du côté de la sûreté du québec qui n'a
pas la responsabilité d'intervenir au
port de montréal
il y à aussi enquête lorsqu'un lien
établi avec le crime organisé sont vient
faire la preuve en fait qu'il s'agit
d'un réseau de voleurs de véhicules
le dossier en fait va être transférée au
service des crimes majeurs la police
mais face à john les tribunaux faudra
faire ceci c'est difficile de commenter
les peines judiciaro vous dire là dessus
parce qu'il n'a à peu près pas c'est pas
un crime qui est sanctionnée c'est
tellement lourd processus criminel
puisque droit criminel est la solution
optimale dans tout aujourd'hui c'est une
question qu'il faut se reposer
quand une voiture est volée c'est
l'ensemble des automobilistes qui en
paient le prix
en 2017 le vol de voiture a coûté aux
assureurs plus de 100 millions de
dollars en réclamation au québec
seulement
un montant que les automobilistes vont
ensuite payer via leurs primes
d'assurance